all right in our first story the ccp the
chinese communist party
is weighing an unprecedented penalty for
didi
the uber of china after they ignored
chinese regulators and went public
anyway
if you remember last week we covered
china's official crackdown
on u.s ipos of their own companies that
was episode 1244
well there's more news to report and i'm
wondering what is china's
endgame here why are they going after
their google their uber their
amazon their square what is china's
endgame here
well i've got some insights on it and uh
let's talk a little bit about it
this was first reported in bloomberg
just this morning chinese regulators i'm
quoting here see the ride-hailing giants
decision to go public
despite pushback from the cyberspace
administration of china as a challenge
to beijing's authority according to
bloomberg's sources
okay that's really interesting a company
in china challenging the chinese
communist party
that seems pretty bold especially in the
face of
you know jack ma and ant and bite dance
really interesting
well chinese officials responded by
starting an on-site investigation
at deities headquarters with members
from the following govern
government agencies attending number one
chinese cyberspace administration the
ministry of public security the ministry
of state security the ministry of
natural resources
along with tax transportation other
anti-trust regulators
i mean this would be the equivalent of
like the fda
ftc faa i mean cia fbi everybody's
coming to your offices
and this has got to be the most
terrorizing thing for a group of
entrepreneurs
to have this many people show up five
different agencies if this is true
it's crazy uh and according to the story
regulators are weighing
a couple of different punishments on top
of not letting people download the app
which was what happened a week or two
ago
now they're talking about a fine okay
how big is the question
a suspension of certain operations oh
boy that's not good
the introduction of a state-owned
investor hmm
oh the state gets to own a piece now
it's starting to sound like a shakedown
that sounds like the most likely one
a tiny fine which is kind of like a vig
they're kind of getting their little tax
through a fine uh who gets that money
interestingly that'll be an interesting
question where does that money go whose
pockets does it go in the states
where does that money get recycled to or
a potential forced
delisting or withdrawal of dd's u.s
shares
uh and here's the quote although it's
unclear how such an option would play
out that would be kind of an
international
incident if you said to
uh the u.s markets and investors in the
united states who bought these shares or
in europe or anywhere else in the world
you are now getting money back for your
shares
i think that means no more chinese
companies going public
in the west the end you're going to go
public do it on your markets
but this could be i don't think that
this is china's end game
i think they want access to
international markets so this is kind of
weird what's going on here
you have to wonder is the chinese
government acting in coordination here
or not and what is their end game what
is the goal
so dd shares dropped seven point four
percent to ten dollars and sixty five
cents at the opening bell today
um and since china began blocking dd's
downloads the market cap for dd has
fallen
uh over 20 billion from 70 billion to 50
billion
which is just crazy and you remember
that they got the cyberspace
administration i can't believe they're
using the word cyber
in the name of their organizations the
regulatory bodies but
this is very similar to what happened to
jack ma's ant financial which was
blocked from going public
uh two days before its trading debut so
in china you're going to
face quick regulation and it's not going
to be a debate like it is in the united
states
some other quotes from the article
regulators urge deedy
to ensure the security of its data
before proceeding with the ipo
or to shift the location to hong kong or
mainland china
uh where disclosure risks would be lower
the people said regulators
didn't explicitly forbid the company
from going public in the us but they
felt certain dd
understood the official instructions
they said why is this quote important
because china did the exact same thing
to bite dance back in march
as we covered last week in the news so
what bike dance did wind up caving to
the ccp and their ceo resigned shortly
after
it seems like dd may have stood up to
the ccp or taking a different
interpretation
and went ahead with their ipos and now
comes the negotiation to
how this goes forward the ccp if i'm
reading this correctly
wanted dd to ipo in hong kong or china
where disclosure risks would be
lower so
is china afraid that its largest tech
companies are inflating numbers or
there's some
lack of um truth here
that's one speculation i guess and maybe
the u.s market is too stringent about
disclosures or maybe
you know china just wants these
companies to be public
in the in their country they want to
reap the benefits they want to have more
controls
that seems more likely so this could be
the great
um i don't want to say disconnection
but it does feel like the integration of
the west and china
and the financial markets is now been
frozen
and uh it might start to reverse so
there's
going to be this pause now does that
mean we're not going to make our iphones
in china that seems like that would be
really hard to do
does it mean apple's not going to get to
sell iphones in china
i don't think that's happening but the
nba
or movies occurring in china that seems
like it could come off the table and
that might not happen in the
in the future years we might not have
access uh to those markets with our
cultural products
and that's fine with me honestly who
cares if we lose 10 percent or 20
percent of
disney's revenue or the nba's revenue in
china
if we can't get to an understanding with
them about reciprocity
and we can't have some basic trending of
human rights in the right direction
or disclosures in the right direction i
think it's time for the west
to maybe step back 20 in this
relationship
certainly taiwan is going to become the
hot button issue in the coming years
and the silicon and the chips made in
taiwan we need to not be dependent on
china
and i think it's kind of lame that you
know the nba
and hollywood are so enamored with china
and so virtual signaling about so many
issues here in america
but you'll never see anybody in
hollywood talk about the three million
uyghurs
in concentration camps being tortured
being forced sterilized
they will not talk about newspapers and
journalists being jailed
in hong kong and hong kong being taken
over and they won't talk about taiwan
so the most virtuous virtue signaling
athletes
actors directors and studio heads are
silent on china's human rights
violations
lame let's just disengage from china on
a cultural basis
and then we'll figure out when it comes
to building products
and you know things that are going to be
a little harder to become independent
we can figure that out later but let's
have the great unraveling
begin i think it's better for everybody
if they want to pursue
a version of humanity which is communist
and authoritarian and we want democracy
let's move our factories to other
countries that are democracies
or you know less authoritarian it's it's
a no-brainer for america
it's a little bit of pain for a lot of
gain in my mind for the human species
if you're a founder you need to check
out dell for entrepreneurs
they have amazing exclusive benefits for
members
entrepreneurs can get free expedited
delivery exclusive offers and up to six
percent
back in rewards you can finance your
entire i.t
project with dell financial services and
you'll have a dedicated startup i.t
advisor to help you with any and all
tech questions
dell has a product line that was
engineered with entrepreneurs in mind
dell's line of
xps laptops and tablets were built for
mobility
they're gorgeous and they have longer
lasting battery life
to increase efficiency when you're on
the go plus
dell is the world's number one monitor
company so you can pair your new
xps machine with the perfect monitor to
realize your vision in fact
i've got two 27 inch monitors on either
side of my desk
right now turn from horizontal to
vertical boom
huge amounts of content to keep me
really
efficient it is absolutely fantastic
over there on my other desk i have two
desks in my office a standing desk and a
regular one
i have a 49 inch curved beautiful dell
monitor
now that's like a whole different level
that's like founder ceo level but
if you want to invest in it i think it's
well worth it because i can have four
windows up
i like the two different setups it gets
me into two different mindsets once
again members of delfor entrepreneurs
receive additional five percent off on
select products
including the xps line which you're
gonna love and they'll help with any itu
projects you may have
go to launch dot co slash down launch
dot co slash dell and sign up for a free
it consultation and five percent off get
that coupon today